céleste revient à son école secondaire
le temps de passage éclair et de
retrouver céleste rentrer de victoria où
étaient réunis depuis janvier les quatre
golfeuses les plus prometteuses au
canada c'est notamment grâce au
programme sport-études de l'école du
chêne-bleu si elle est devenue l'un des
joyaux du golf canadien
on va tenter de présenter à la ronde de
golf à la télévision le plus possible
pour que les jeunes soient fiables de ce
futur bain cette future athlète
professionnel à 17 ans céleste a dépassé
les attentes
tellement qu'elle s'est qualifié pour
l'omnium des états-unis en l'emportant
par quatre coups un tournoi réservé aux
joueuses de niveau amateur de cette
expérience là avec ma famille c'est
vraiment important pour moi que mon père
se moquer des piquets donc israël va
venir me suivent avec ma mère je suis
vraiment reconnaissante pour joly dao le
golf est en effet une histoire de
famille mon père céleste et son frère de
14 ans ont été initiés au golf par leur
père d'origine vietnamienne duc dao et
son épouse annie ont été exigeants j'ai
évité le plus longtemps possible de
parler que ce soit de professionnels
j'ai jamais mentionné ça au départ j'ai
dit on va jouer mais on va toujours se
mesurer que les meilleurs parce que mais
ils n'ont pas su ma force
gène cretz j'ai fait le thema daniel
santerre a été le premier enseignant de
céleste au cloud sans bruit ces deux là
font équipe depuis dix ans selon lui
elle sera capable de se hisser parmi les
75 premières même s'il n'a que 17 ans on
essaie que soient déterminées alpha
autrement dit cap pense qu'à ça fait si
ça se fait est assez forte pour la fin
en alabama à son premier tournoi avec
des professionnels céleste aura son père
à ses côtés sur le parcours entre chacun
de ses élans la directive sera clair via
vos pattes avant chaque rond
le jour parce que sa main comme si je
pense trop gueule ça ça me déconcentre
j'aime ce cas il parle de quelque chose
qui est vraiment fort à pons c'est
lorsqu'on m'a duc accepte volontiers les
recommandations de céleste en
contrepartie les parents de la golfeuse
ont aussi les leurs durant les tournois
et les entraînements si je fais ça par
synchro perte de temps qui peut nuire à
mon col mais je peux pas de soulager
jeunes adolescents et pour son bien
aussi celle veut évidemment elle est au
niveau qu'elle est qu'elle désire
atteindre là c'est de trouver un
équilibre entre tous à ces listes
détient déjà une entente verbale avec
l'université georgia prête à financer
ses études aux etats unis son école
secondaire l'a décoré du prix du
gouverneur pour ses résultats scolaires
et son engagement communautaire sa
participation au us open est une autre
récompense je serai pendant longtemps
jean françois poirier est du canada à
vaudreuil dorion